la chronique environnement avec vos
valérie comme chaque mardi et votre
vitesse au soir absolument wilfried ce
soir nous avons parlé biodiversité
urbaine puisque la faune et la flore
part à l'appart à la reconquête des
villes et à saint quentin en yvelines
cette politique verte est impulsée par
bouygues construction à guyancourt et
donc pour nous en parler ce soir olivier
lemoine bonsoir vous êtes écologue et
naturaliste responsable de la
biodiversité d'élan filiale de bouygues
est donc première question qu est ce qu
un écologue alors oui c'est surprenant à
cologne écologistes non un écolo c'est
un scientifique efficacement tout le
monde les gens connaissent l'écologie
l'écologie c'est la prise de conscience
de la nécessité de sauver la planète et
les gens qui le font sur une action
politique
il ya des gens qui le font avec une
approche scientifique donc l'écologie
c'est une science est une science du
vivant de la faune de la flore des
écosystèmes et les écologues sont les
scientifiques qui pratique qui
connaissent cette science salaire vous
plus clair comme ça voilà vous avez un
vrai un vrai parcours des collègues et
des naturalistes est-ce que vous pouvez
nous nous dessiner ce parcours en
quelques mots bon j'ai pas très court je
dirais que tout petit je me suis
intéressé la nature pour pourquoi dire
c'est parce que avec mon père n'avait
construit une cabane pour nourrir des
oiseaux j'avais des jumelles et observer
les oiseaux les différentes espèces
d'oiseaux donc j'ai commencé tout petit
après j'ai fait des études scientifiques
poussées jusqu'à une thèse en écologiste
royer sur les chouettes toujours les
oiseaux et puis après j'ai j'ai créé mon
entreprise j'avais 26 ans cabinet
conseil en écologie en normandie pendant
20 ans un peu plus de vingt ans et j'ai
souhaité rentrer dans un grand groupe
pour changer d'échelle je suis rentré
dans groupe bouygues il ya trois ans
comme quoi construire sa petite cabane
pour les oiseaux ça mène jusqu'à a fondé
sa société dès l'âge de 26 ans est donc
aujourd'hui
vous évoquez la biodiversité urbaine
avec nous qu'est ce que la biodiversité
urbaine la biodiversité urbaine c'est la
nature c'est la faune et la flore c'est
les oiseaux dans les villes pendant
longtemps on a on a opposé la ville et
la campagne
la campagne s'était là où il y avait de
la nature et la ville c'était là où je
faisais des activités autres aujourd'hui
les limites entre la ville la ville
s'est étendue 1 est allé dans la
campagne et puis et puis la nature re
rentrer dans les villes donc c'est toute
cette préoccupation pour re me remettre
un petit peu là la faune la flore
l'heure c'est un petit peu différent de
l' approche plus années 70 on travaille
essentiellement sur des espaces verts
des pelouse de la verdure puisque là où
s'intéresse aux écosystèmes à quoi ils
servent
quels qu'ils apportent aux dom toute
leur diversité la faune la flore etc
alors cette politique verte est vraiment
impulsée par bouygues notamment sur son
site challenger si elle lui en cours
vous pouvez nous nous expliquer en fait
ce qui s'est développé vraiment sur ce
site qui est assez particulier alors
bout de construction a décidé d'être
leader dans la construction durable dire
quoi la construction durable c'est la
construction qui intègre les critères de
développement durable pas parler de la
construction écologique nous construire
des villes écologiques surtout quand on
est bâtisseur l'idée c'est d'associer à
la construction durable il ya des
thématiques techniques comme par exemple
toutes les questions énergétiques
d'associer aussi l'aller les questions
de nature et sur challenger challenger
cc c'est un grand espace avec un grand
parc etc
on avait un formidable lieu pour faire
la démonstration qu'on peut à côté du
bâtiment se préoccuper de bd re cité
c'était une volonté de cette entreprise
c'est aussi une obligation maintenant
parce que pour avoir vraiment cette
étiquette verte et de mieux vendre les
activités il faut être en phase avec
l'écologie au sens large
respecter l'environnement selon
d'obligation morale au sens où où
effectivement sauver la nature tout le
monde se doit un petit peu de le faire
mais quand on est en ville on n'est pas
dans le schéma des espèces très rares
très peu protégés quand on a un mail qui
chante dans une cour d'immeuble quand on
a des maisons et cetera c'est pas
forcément fin des espèces qui sont très
rares qui sont à protéger
donc on n'est pas
dans le cas de l'obligation
réglementaire qu'on peut avoir quand par
ailleurs on construit un grand
autoroutes et là on est obligé de faire
attention
là on le fait plutôt par par envie
d'apporter des éléments de bien-être de
qualité de vie aux habitants aux usagers
etc
ces vendeurs il a notamment bossé pour
ça oui oui il ya une demande il ya à la
fois une demande c'est un sujet qui
plaît la biodiversité parce que la
nature est un sujet sur ancestrale fin
les gens ont besoin
moi dit toujours que la nature est un
élément du bonheur pouvoir se lever le
matin puis voir que les hirondelles sont
arrivés etc
c'est un élément important et à
challenger dans les parkings thunder
nous avons des hirondelles qui nie qui
niche qui font leur nid donc on n'a pas
ça dans notre parking mais pourtant il
ya bien des conventions internationales
qui incite aujourd'hui les villes les
communes les les états à aller vers vers
ce type de construction et de ville tout
à fait vain il ya un mouvement général
qui dit que les hommes ne peuvent plus
se contenter d'abîmer la nature donc il
faut il faut veiller à protéger ou vous
reconstituer la nature et on s'inscrit
dans cette dans cette dynamique tout à
fait faire une petite pour y tomber mon
va écouter les saint quentinois nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre pour leur
demander seriez vous prêt à vivre dans
une maison écologique mais en bois le
moi c'est assez tendance en ce moment
voici vos réponses et des pulls et vous
pourrez réagir ensuite sur ce plateau
oui oui bah faire des économies déjà et
pour la planète
enfin comme les deux vont assembler les
descend très bas voire volontiers si on
m'offre pourquoi pas ça dépends d'eads
et du confort qui peut être proposé
ouais éventuellement pourquoi pas oui
c'est tout dépenses et ça peut être très
intéressant une maison en bois ont fait
la raison pour des raisons écologiques
c'est en général le bois est un bon
isolant
en toute logique on peut penser qu'au
niveau du chauffage on aurait à payer
les frais dans important mais si j'avais
c'est la possibilité oui pour quelle
raison d'un plein de raisons tous et
plus économique
et puis bon ben il faut il faut il faut
le faire quoi je pense que maintenant
oui m'enfin je me méfie un petit peu des
tendances je pense que l'écologie ça
commence par des gestes simples sans vie
dans une maison écolo une maison en bois
oui pourquoi pas parce que c'est
chaleureux effectivement c'est le bois
le bois c'est une belle matière d'eau
parce que c'est écolo que ça préserve
l'environnement
par contre ce que je sais c'est que ça
reste encore très cher à construire et à
faire et donc ça ce sera rédhibitoire
pour l'instant des maisons écolos en
bois pour tous c'est presque un slogan
est ce que c'est une réalité pour
bientôt m'a demandé à l'écologue ce
qu'ils en pensent quoi vous vous
demandiez montcoal qu'on a un
spécialiste la partie en bois
si vous construction mais ça marche bien
oui oui ça marche vraiment et je dirai
simplement dans les propos qu'on a
entendu il ya plusieurs choses c'est la
maison il ya deux questions économiques
il ya les questions techniques
et puis ya beaucoup de gens qui qui
évoquait la notion du sens c'est
écologique parce que le bois c'est
renouvelable moi c'est des forêts donc
on est bien quand on construit en bois
on est bien dans les cautionne pas je
vous donne une réponse des colloques ont
été investis dans ce que je me disais au
début de cette séquence à voilà on est
bien lorsque l'environnement est au tour
de nos convives bien dans son écosystème
alors justement qu'est ce que la
biodiversité urbaine apporte à l'homme
concrètement alors elle apporte
plusieurs sources elle rend des services
ans on s'est rendu compte que des villes
sans biodiversité ça manquait que la
présence belge
elle peut les rendre rendre des services
techniques très concret par an le fait
d'avoir des arbres le terme fait d'avoir
des plans d'eau foire des zones humides
sa évapore sa évapotranspiration réduit
la chaleur et ça réduit l'îlot de
chaleur on a moins de canicule rappelez
vous les grandes canicules on disait aux
gens
mettez-vous à l'ombre d'un arbre et
s'est donc donc ça rend ces services là
et puis ça permet aussi de voir évoluer
les saisons de rythme et sa vie ça
participe de l' équilibre et puis ça va
ça apporte aussi beaucoup de service
culture monsieur je prends toujours un
exemple si je dis aux gens aux familles
un posez vous la question où vos enfants
auront vu leur première grenouille leur
premier pétard est ce que ça sera en
vacances très loin
etc où est ce que ça sera dans un fossé
à côté de la zone où vous habitez de la
zone commerciale où il ya un jour en se
mettant à genoux il aura découvert qu'il
ya des têtards et des grenouilles donc
c'est tout ce côté éducatif plaisir et
aussi services rendus épuration
régulation du climat par exemple et est
ce que les entreprises viennent vers
vous pour justement concevoir des parcs
avait-elle que challenger
alors on n'est pas un paysagiste donc on
conçoit pas départ qu'on va plutôt
orienté des programmes etc
mais effectivement vous avez dans les
filiales donc élan et qui donne qui fait
des unes des missions de conseil et
c'est donc beaucoup de clients qui nous
aident à traiter différemment leurs
espaces verts citant texte la place
alors ça peut être des parts mais ça
peut être aussi mettre de la
biodiversité sur du bâtiment sur du
minéral quand on n'a pas de l'espace
suffisant donc la biodiversité urbaine
c'est aussi moins de pesticides en ville
évidemment évidemment vous savez que
dans des endroits ont mis le plus de
pesticides aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
arrêté un peu partout c'est sur les
terrasses des immeubles où on traite
pour pas que les herbes arrive alors que
sur les terrasses on pourrait avoir des
petits écosystème qui s'installerait au
lieu de mettre des pesticides et
herbicides ou pardon que la ville béton
c'est fini c'est probablement fini je
pense qu'au xxième siècle la ville sera
plus verte entourant aura aura des
quartiers et des coulées vertes beaucoup
plus que les vite dépassé à quelle
échéance
rapidement on pourra le voir il faudra
attendre le temps que les nouveaux
grands projets arrivent se réalise et
puis et puis mature un petit peu même
une danse une échéance de quelques
décennies je veux dire merci ça commence
maintenant
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau non
c'est maintenant plus sur cette
profession des colloques savait tout sur
le métier dès colog merci valérie deux
informations pour conclure sa chronique
oui absolument où il ferait de la
première édition de paroles de
jardiniers vient de s'achever après un
mois d'animations organisées sur
l'ensemble du département
les collaborations de 46 propriétaires
de jardins privés et sites publics a
permis à yvelines tourisme d'orchestrés
200 animations et de réunir plus de 21
mille visiteurs une fermeture
d'entreprise oui on sait
unis pme françaises à fabriquer des
composants électroniques pour les
panneaux solaires vient de déposer le
bilan si tu es à mantes la jolie
cette entreprise créée en 1973 vient
donc de licencier une quinzaine de
personnes une entreprise sans doute
victime des aides qui se sont réduites
pour installer une banda crise
merci valérie à mardi prochain pour un
autre point environnement ou innovation
aussi vous le savez si vous vous êtes
des fidèles de l'émission nous allons
finir le set 8 en évoquant la présence
halloween la fête a perdu de la vitesse
ces dernières années certains continuent
à organiser des rendez vous c'est le cas
du centre alfred de vigny les détails à
suivre ce sera juste après ce reportage
d'alice gastines et de patrick jacques
de dixmude ils se sont penchés sur le
marché des pompes funèbres un
développement notable celui de la
crémation
c'est un phénomène qui est apparu il y a
quelques années de plus en plus de
français se tournent vers la crémation
selon un sondage ifop pour les pompes
funèbres générales la demande est
actuellement de 32% et devrait atteindre
50% d'ici une dizaine d'années
explications avec un professionnel du
métier devant les cavurnes du cimetière
des gones arts à versailles le coût des
obsèques crémation sont en moyenne sur
la région parisienne de 3500 euros et en
inhumation d'environ 4500 euros pour les
personnes qui n'ont pas encore
deux concessions
funéraire dans un cimetière pour des
inhumations il faudra acquérir cette
concession faire un monument funéraire
donc ce qui va augmenter la facture
d'eau tant d'autres facteurs expliquent
cette hausse comme le manque de place
dans les cimetières en région parisienne
certaines personnes considèrent aussi
que la crémation est plus écologique que
l'inhumation une demande de plus en plus
difficiles à satisfaire
compte tenu du manque de crématorium la
france en compte aujourd'hui 144 pour
plus de 160000 crémations par an il faut
effectivement que la france s'équipant
crématorium nous sommes un petit peu en
retard au niveau de ses équipements
les yvelines compte un seul crématorium
situé aux mureaux la construction d'un
tel édifice est à l'initiative des
communes sur appel d'offres auprès des
professionnels des pompes funèbres
par ailleurs la loi oblige les communes
de plus de 2000 habitants à disposer
d'un site cinéraire